this is I think the most important
message from today that it was possible
really to fix all these files today
first was we adopted the regulation on
administrative cooperation on which we
reached general approach back in June
this year second we reached political
agreement on via tea rules on eep
applications which was also very
important for all our countries and
today we succeeded third we agreed to
fix four issues with the current vit
rules that cause problems for businesses
and tax administration which was also
hard discussed over many month and today
we could fix it in this case the fourth
file was that we agreed to prolong the
application of the sectoral reverse
charge mechanism and of the quick
reaction mechanism the fifth was that we
also today agreed on the rules that will
permit member states which are most
affected by vit fraud to temporarily
apply the generalized v80 reverse charge
mechanism these so-called
quick fixes would reduce compliance
costs and increase legal certainty for
businesses once the European Parliament
has published its report on this file
the new rules should be enforceable by
2020